- Look, you're quivering.
- I can't, oh my.
- You're quivering.
- Don't judge me.
You eat that.
- I've never wanted to walk
off a set more than now.
(suspenseful music)
- Live and direct from Hollywood.
- It's Feast Mode Hunger Squad.
We're doing this again.
- We're eating fish jizz.
- Cod sperm.
- It's actually called shirako.
- We're gonna go to two
restaurants that serve.
- The finest cod sperm
in all of Los Angeles.
- I'm pretty excited.
- I'm sad.
- I have a feeling that cod
sperm is actually delicious.
- I've also heard that it's pretty good.
- Don't want to eat this stuff.
- I'm all about it.
I'm a 21st century man.
- This used to be fun.
- We're keeping Nicky in the dark.
She has no idea what we're gonna go eat.
- I'm so excited but I
don't know what we're doing.
(sinister laughter)
- [Colin] I want a (mumbles) excitement.
- [Steven] Let's roll, let's go.
- We used to eat like
fun things like donuts.
- [Steven] It is gonna be fun.
- Okay, so we're on our way
to the first restaurant.
It's called Shunji.
I'm still terrified.
- [Nicky] Wait, you're terrified?
- Yes.
- [Hostess] Welcome to Shunji.
- [Steven] Thank you.
We heard a lot of things
about your shirako.
- Mmhmm, there are several
different kind of shirako,
depends on the fish, but
right now we use cod.
It's a egg of cod,
male egg of cod.
Some people call milt.
- Okay.
- So, it's cod sperm.
Are you excited?
- [Hostess] The taste is really good.
We are going to make one dish,
it's called Chowanmushi.
Chowanmushi is like a
Japanese egg custard pudding.
- [Nicky] Oh, I love that stuff.
Yeah.
- [Hostess] And we add shirako.
- Oh. (laughter)
Thank you.
- Is it warm?
Oh, it's warm guys.
- Woah, it definitely looks like sperm.
- It looks crazy.
- [Colin] It looks like a
fish beat off into a cup.
- Like, it reminds me of
miso soup made out of jizz.
- [Colin] I didn't
expect it to look so much
like the real thing.
- Yeah.
- There's a lot in here.
This is like from one fish.
One, two, three.
(suspenseful music)
(sound of disgust)
- No.
- It's tasty.
- Mm-mm, no.
- When I put it in my
mouth, it rejects it.
- Yum.
- It's very much a mental thing.
- Kind of has the exact same texture.
- It's creamy.
- [Colin] Very mild, sort of musky flavor.
- Texture would get a ten
because it's that identical
to the real thing.
- I feel mildly horny.
Probably a five out of ten there.
- I feel like my cod
maybe had some pineapple
before I got busy.
- Straight taste, I would
say it's like an eight.
- It's not for me.
(sound of enjoyment)
- Well, I'm gonna eat yours, Freddie.
Clean plate club round two.
- Now we've tried cod sperm.
We're going to compare
it to another place.
- We're going to a place called Hamasaku.
- [Freddie] We'll see what
this next place has in store.
Today, we're kind of like, going around LA
and trying to find the best cod milt.
Do a lot of people order that here?
- Yes, last time we sold out.
I mean, certain days we do sell out.
- Oh, wow.
- It just depends on who comes in.
We're doing it thee
different ways for you.
Two of them are going to be cooked
and one is going to be raw.
- We're about to die then.
- Let's do it.
You guys ready?
- Yeah, we're ready.
- Tempura style guys.
- Outside's great, inside is oh.
- Yum.
- It kind of gave me
the vibe of an oyster.
- [Steven] What is the texture?
- Fried cum ball.
- Creaminess is on fleek.
- Tempura style is better.
- This is how you get
kids to start liking it.
- Woah.
- Wow.
Wow.
- [Colin] Smells like Christmas in there.
- That was literally an
explosion of flavors in my mouth.
- That was really good.
- Tens across the board
on every flavor possible.
- Like little bit of
guacamole and the fig.
I thought the fig was a nice touch.
- This fig was great.
- That shit was fancy as fuck.
- I might be a little
milted out at this point.
- [Steven] You know, we
got the raw coming right?
- (laughs) It's just like it doesn't end.
- This is it.
- [Host] Cod milt in it purest form.
- [Steven] The ultimate boss.
- You can see like veins.
- Honestly and truly at this point, guys,
I might have to like, dip out.
- [Nicky] You've come this
far, there's one left.
- Look, you're quivering.
- I can't, oh my.
- You're quivering.
- Don't judge me.
You eat that, go.
(suspenseful music)
- [Colin] Steven, come on.
That was barely a bite.
- I just had to swallow
it whole, 'cause I can't.
- I can't.
- [Nicky] Steven, we all did it.
- Raw is not my thing.
- [Colin] Steven, come on.
- Steven, Steven.
- There you go.
There you go.
- Woah, super cummy.
- [Nicky] Raw, cod sperm.
You can't judge that.
There's no rubric here.
- This cod sperm was next level.
- Screw you for inviting me to this one.
- Woah.
- I have never wanted to walk off a set
more than now.
- I can't pick a favorite.
They were all sperm.
- I don't think I'm tired
but I'm emotionally troubled.
- I'm glad I took a journey.
It was an experience.
- Yeah, I don't judge
people who eat this stuff,
it's just not for me.
- [Steven and Freddie] Jizz kids.
- This has been Steven,
Freddie, Nicky and Colin.
We out.
What should we do next time
on Feast Mode Hunger Squad?
Let's go.
(suspenseful music)